notorious nightmare online poster matt
walsh really gave away the game here
saying
he wants to find one person in the us
who really wants to vote that would find
it difficult to do so then he goes on to
say that things like voter id
work as an extremely basic iq test for
voters he hasn't impeached we've said
this before and we'll say it again
republicans are putting these voter
suppression laws into place because they
want to choose the voters notorious
nightmare and poster that i kind of like
i might put that on my resume if i had
one this is not the quiet part out loud
for me because it's never been the quiet
part yes i want fewer people to vote
lots of the people who vote right now i
wish that they were legally prevented
from doing so case in point the video we
just watched
when you've got just these legions mobs
of drooling morons stupid people vote
stumbling half drunk into the voting
booth uh every four years or every two
years and like randomly pushing a button
or making a selection based on a letter
next to a name that's that's not voting
that's just like that's just rolling
dice